I asked on your subreddit which is an
excellent subreddit shout out to the
destiny subreddit so much uh at least
for that particular post what I really
loved is when I asked for questions for
you they were like holy [ __ ] there's
adults in there let's all behave yeah
like nobody say incest I was like what
what's going on here but actually the
the questions that Rose to the top are
really good so uh somebody said that
Destiny was
speaking of your journey was a
conservative in his early teens then he
became a Libertarian then he became a
left-wing social justice Warrior then he
flirted with socialism and now he is a
Social Democrat liberal I've also I
heard you referred to yourself as a far
left person so to the degree there's
truth to that Journey can you take me
through your evolution
uh through the landscape of political
ideologies
that you went through so my dad comes
from Kentucky and my mom is a Cuban
immigrant uh Cubans are notorious for
being very conservative in the United
States for historical reasons and for
other reasons but um my upbringing was a
very Republican one I grew up listening
to Rush Limbaugh Glenn Beck Michael
Savage on the radio Billy Cunningham
I think Sean Hannity a little bit later
on like uh that was like my whole
upbringing politically I remember I was
writing
I'd written like articles for the school
Journal like in favor of uh defending
the war in Iraq and you know defending
bush from all the criticism et cetera so
that was my upbringing I think once I
hit High School College I had my edgy
like libertarian-esque high school phase
of like reading Ayn Rand
um of figuring out that like oh my God
nothing in life matters except for class
and money that's actually the answer to
everything and I got to college I became
a Ron Paul fan very big Ron Paul fan and
then
from there I kind of work do life life
happens at the kind of the lowest point
of my life in terms of where I'm working
financially everything is like kind of
in ruined in my life there's a whole
bunch of dumb stuff that's happened
probably my most conservative point I
don't know what it is about like being
poor and thinking like you can work your
way out of it you can do whatever it's
just my upbringing is always like if
you're not if you're not if you're not
having financial success work work work
work
um and then I got into streaming very
very lucky break everything just lined
up at the right time and then as I've
progressed through streaming I would say
through the years I've gradually Fallen
more and more to the left especially
once my kid turned four five six years
old and I started to see like how much
different his life was just because of
the financial opportunities that I was
able to provide for him through no merit
of his own and that started to radically
change how I viewed the world in a lot
of ways so actually let's like lingo on
that yeah low point
he worked at McDonald's you worked at a
casino
you uh did carpet cleaning what was the
the lowest point definitely the carpet
cleaning really absolutely why why was
it the lowest point that's when you were
just flirting with starting uh streaming
my whole life has been a series of Lucky
breaks really truly uh I grew up playing
a lot of video games but back in my day
our day
um you had to read there's a lot of text
on the screen back in my day we used to
play they didn't all talk stuck yeah
because nowadays everything's voice
acted but back then you'd read a lot I
was a really good reader and a really
good vocabulary yeah where'd you
actually say that what games are we
talking about what what do you mean just
reading you're talking about like RPG
yeah jrpg so like Final Fantasy games
fantasy stars like all of these like any
RPG that would have been on the SNES
Sega PlayStation these are the things
that I'm pause on that okay I just
talked to Todd Howard who's
um of the Elder Scrolls Fame and the
Fallout Fame and Beyond what's your
thoughts on Elder Scrolls why is Skyrim
the greatest RPG of all time man and I
really don't like Skyrim or Fallout
games oh really no not at all why do you
hate Skyrim yeah so I really like
characters and like compelling stories
and narratives around those characters
and I like to see them kind of like grow
and change kind of like a movie or a
story so in your like Final Fantasy
games you've got characters
um there are a lot of like um like
classical tropes of like a character
starts off kind of like edgy angsty all
on their own they develop relationships
friendships they realize that the life
is more about themselves and they do
that and I like that that growth that's
kind of what you see in all of those old
uh role-playing games
um I didn't like the open world ones as
much because your main character is just
like a blank slate never talks it's for
you to like project onto but there's not
the same like uh linear Narrative of
like growth for the character that's
fascinating There's an actual story arc
to the character that's more crafted
yeah in a beautiful way by the designers
of the game yeah that's the only one is
better or worse I tend towards like I
want to hear a compelling story around
like a set of characters that like grow
and changes again oh that's beautifully
put in yeah I I just really loved being
able to leave the town
you go outside the town and you look
outside it's nature and the world of
possibilities is before you you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want I mean that
immensity of just being lost in the
world is really immersive for me but
yeah you're right whatever attracts you
about a world so you were just starting
to
play video games you go out play the
video games that's one of your lucky
breaks there's just like a lot of random
skills you pick up depending on the type
of game you play I played a lot of
text-based games on the computer so I
was a very fast typer I'm still a very
fast typer
um read a lot you know learned weird
kind of math stuff for some of the
calculations some of the games I think
I'm pretty good at getting information
figuring stuff out learning patterns all
of that and then that plus the reading
and everything of the games meant that I
I don't want to say I excelled in school
because my grades were pretty bad but I
was in like all honors all AP classes or
whatever a lot of dual enrollment a lot
of AP credit going into college so I did
pretty well in school probably better
than I should have but it was because I
had the game stuff that was like really
powering a lot of my brain there while I
was trying to sleep through class so
yeah so you're able to soak in
information integrate it and be quickly
take notes generally I think I'm pretty
good at that yeah what uh you do this a
lot when you stream your typing stuff is
there a system in that note taking and
what note what do you use for note
taking uh doesn't matter I use a notepad
notepad the original C notepad yep
notepad.exe not the plus plus not is
there genius to the madness behind that
or you just don't give a [ __ ] no I mean
like it's going to depend on the style
of conversation if I'm with somebody
that is very meticulously organized
their thoughts and they're a uh find a
better word here for Rambler you can
edit that in better word for Rambler
yeah something that talks a lot a lot
I'll start like taking notes bullet
points like this this this this this
this because um there's a style of
conversation where I say seven or eight
different things and then when you go to
respond to everything I said I cut you
off immediately and we argue that point
but if somebody's gonna do that he's
just like hold on you just said these
eight things I'm going to respond to
every single one I've written them all
down and then you can go if you want to
go Point by point we can but you just
said all this and I wrote it down so
we're gonna go so what are you actually
writing down like a couple of words per
point they left honestly like there are
very few unique conversations in
politics like a lot of them are kind of
retreading old ground so for having a
debate on abortion
um somebody might say like oh well I
believe this thing about viability and I
believe this thing about you know when
when there are fetus versus a human and
I'll just write down like those points
so that when I go to respond I kind of
have like a like note cards like a
guiding thing there to keep me centered
on my response political discourse is
the kind of tree you're walking down I
got it and you're like taking just to
keep my focus guided so I'm not like
running off on a weird tangent or
responding to something I didn't say or
something yeah what about like doing
research it's just is there a system to
your note-taking because mentally you
seem to be one of the most organized
people I've listened to so is there is
it in your mind or is there a system
that's on paper a little of both I feel
like the human mind is a beautiful thing
if you have interest in an area uh so
like what I'll tell people is let's say
there's like a totally new topic that
I'm researching I don't know anything
and I'll do a couple of these on stream
I think they're born people watch it I
might open a Wikipedia article and I'll
read and I hit something I don't know
and then I open the next Wikipedia
article and I'll read into and then I
might have like seven tabs open and I'll
read and I'll read and I'll read
um and I'll read a ton of stuff maybe
for hour two three four hours of stuff
and then by the end you know someone in
chat will ask me like do you even
remember like this this particular thing
and I'll say not really no not too much
but what happens is as long as you've
seen it once what will happen is like
the next day of the day after we'll read
something else and we're like oh I
remember that thing from this thing I
remember like vaguely that and then if
you see it like a third time you're like
oh this makes sense because especially
when it comes to oh here's like a little
trick on stuff if you ever reading any
news and there's a place that pops up
always look at it on a map because so
much of history is like on a map it's so
important to like know the geography it
makes things make so much more sense
um but yeah once I once I start to see
stuff over and over again just because
I've like read it a few times stuff will
start to kind of connect to my mind and
like oh yeah well this makes sense of
course these people believe this because
of this or of course like this happened
here it's because you know that happened
there
um so yeah it's a lot of that if there's
like a topic that I'm doing specific
research for
um so like vaccine related stuff is a
big one the Ukrainian Russian conflict
is a big one that I'll break out a note
um I'll probably get like a Google doc
and I'll just start like writing like an
outline of kind of the rough points of
everything just to organize is my
thoughts around different topics yeah